hi in this video I am going to talk
about
graphpad prism 7 introductory video
photographed by prism 7 the latest
version of graph pad so let's open the
graph pad prism 7 so here's our graph by
prism 7 now it would say welcome to
graphpad prism and there are a lot of
options over here you can see there
option for new table and graphs it says
X Y that means your graphs would look
look like somewhat base and 4 and this
XY graphs are very important for
plotting mathematical functions
correlation etc the column graphs would
be very important for plotting your
experimental data such as you did a
control set of experiment vs. are
treated and you can see a sample over
here then you have grouped graphs then
you have survival contingency and pie
chart also which is called part as a
whole over graphpad prism so there are
other options like open a previously
done file you can see there are many
files over here they have a lab archive
and they have option for introduction
about graphs so they have given all the
options for many graphs and description
about those graphs so you can see there
are many graphs you can just go there
and study about these graphs and when to
use these graphs so in this particular
video I'm going to talk about how to
enter our data and how to do our column
graph so let's go and make our column
graph so in order to make a column graph
we would click on column after clicking
on column we would enter our replicate
values step in columns and we want to
represent our data as mean of our data
set plus/minus standard error so we
would choose that after choosing that
they would give an option for
statistical analysis we won't click here
because we would be the statistical Isis
later so when we said create it would
open a new page so let's say we want to
measure and we want to graphically
represent the difference in Heights
between the male and female students of
our class so we would write here male
and in the next color we would write
female and their heights are given in
centimeters so we I would just enter
only 5 data for males and 5 data for
females so let's enter the data let's
say there are five data for males and
five data would be for female
so after that we want to make a graph on
that and we want to see whether there is
a significant difference between the
height of male and the female
so after entering this particular data
you go to the side bar where you can see
there is a data option under the graphs
so when you click on that you would see
a pivot graph is auto-generated you just
have to click OK you can see there is a
bar diagram showing them when you click
over here when you bring your cursor
over here you can find the mean height
for the female group is actually 1 54.8
and for male it's 1/6 8.8 so it's given
and the standard error of mean is also
represented in the graph you can put our
X title and up put a Y title so let's my
title we would write height in
centimeters and then you can give a
title or we can we can also use the X
title or if you want to add exciting
that doesn't matter and then we can edit
these graphs change the colors like for
changing color we have to double click
on the particular graph when we double
click a new window would open and there
have to select new colors let's say I am
choosing this blue color and when we
click OK the color is changed we can
also change the style of that x axis by
clicking double clicking on it by
particularly double clicking on it they
want to change the label and write the
level as below horizontal now the level
would have appear in a horizontal
fashion and so the two graphs are ready
in another video I would show our
statistical analysis to tell whether the
height of male students significantly
different from female students and
that's all about this tutorial and if
you like my video please give it a quick
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
and please leave your comments below
thank you